okay so this is a mortal recoil and yes
are keeping the uncomfortable disturbing
tone aren't they definitely love
exorcist under overtones it is yeah no
definitely I mean like even dances you
saw had like a polkadot nightgown hot
and stuff I mean like they're definitely
referencing that the sauce is one thing
okay it starts off first I just I'll
give props it starts off the title card
with a grave and they're all looking set
and of course my first thought is oh
never referenced again so that's pretty
funny I thought that was really good so
that they bring her in touch her ice
cream is work out and then dr. princess
that is running joke and they Isle of
their medical says they were more sugar
or sweet does two scoops of sugar yes
ninety percent is gross the other 10% is
crazy disgusting or so yes be crazy
that's so really funny episode by the
way just liked really hard at this one
so they have to so she comes back okay
ish it turns out she's possessed by the
Lich and is doing all sorts of crazy
things and turns into this big giant
monster starts destroying the town it
turns out they need Ice King even though
Finn is really angry at Ice King because
he's the one that dropped her in there
and you know now in hindsight that that
annoyance in the first episode works
better mm-hmm you know now I'm sort of
like okay it's you know even though it's
funny before it's like now I really get
why cuz then had to be really angry
ahead to create her in a nice arc when
he have to ask the ice came for home so
it's a freezer
so Susan big monster the Ice King
freezes her she falls over breaks into a
million pieces
yes again just like my favorite reaction
they're all happy and cheering when
she's frozen and she breaks and the look
on
Bin's face and then shake just going
yeah so funny I mean those were such
good reactions um and he'd take her back
to the hospital and there wasn't quite a
bubble gun that they could find so they
put together what they can and it means
she's younger she's 13 now where she was
what 18 yeah 18 it's like I don't know
it she looks like 15 at the oldest to me
I don't know but but now they're
apparently they're the same age and now
she's like really in love with VIN you
know she's like my hero and all that
stuff and he blushes and you know that's
the episode well first of all thank you
for showing this in that order because
you're right I think it's a much better
season finale yeah you know even if
that's not what they show and it just it
is I mean what a much better place to
end it because it's like well what does
this mean are they going to you know are
they gonna be Mormon I don't know or is
she gonna be different it's it's a great
place to leave it
so we'll you were asking about the Lich
boom so what's the last shot of the oh
yeah and the snail do ya the sale has
gone from like just this little thing
you knows to now suddenly this big thing
that ladies probably gonna be carrying
the Lich the whole time it's gonna be
like the big villain or something so
yeah a lot you know get really a lot of
creepy stuff you know not necessarily
like you know hey don't show this to
kids necessary but it's like it was
really unnerving a lot of it there's
just a gifts or this tone like even like
I think the scariest thing is just her
sitting on the bed just going it's like
creepy my favorite is when like Jake is
trying to sing to her and she just goes
Lou and she's just melting everywhere
and she's like yeah I'm like yeah or
even no and when she first starts to
kiss at first it's sort of like you know
what you go like that oh that's catfight
because she has the deep voice but then
she's like oh oh oh it's like yeah I'm
like getting that feeling like what I
saw yeah obsessed which I know is what
they're going for it but you know it
we're relatively well yeah um I also
left really hard when Finn is going out
going after
or with the likelike sweater and just
this might be the funniest one of the
funniest camera angles I ever saw he
leaves towards her and the cameras
following in from behind you know uh and
then she smacks him away and the camera
still keeps out of it just flies
backwards it's just this great
anti-climatic moment where you think
it's gonna be this big you know this big
punch or something it's just flung right
baggage aside really really funny well
I'm not affected in the last episode
they make it where it's the sweater that
kind of saves the day
yeah here it doesn't nothing exactly
it's it's the nice thing of yes
sometimes it'll help them sometimes it
won't
mmm really liking someone doesn't always
save the day sometimes you just need to
freeze their asses so yeah I really
liked it it felt like a really big
episode too and it had a lot of
characters in there and now I enjoyed it
a great deal haven't you I loved when
they walked in and people's is drinking
the from the tub and smacks them through
the wall and there's ice king with the
cup again I forgot but yeah no that's an
R great job I love it I love jokes I
don't the image of somebody listening
with a little paper cup it's like so
pathetic yeah and it always makes me
laugh so it's just that little throwaway
joke just listening it's just coming
through the one very funny very very
good stuff I also liked it too beginning
when you know of course the Ice King is
like say go my wife blah blah blah and
he's trying to explain that he saw
something strange happen and fin so
pissed off about what's been going on
that he says you know being here and
when it's something that's really
relevant and really really important and
everyone's just like whatever go away
you're old you're you're crazy and I'm
really uh yeah yeah and I loved raggedy
princess yes that there's so many good
things in this episode uh like she is
that her first appearance of first
appear as that character I don't think
it's her first but I so first him to
give her a name as far as I remember I
she had like two lines and I'm like that
character was hilarious design was so
strange and then just like that's one of
the things I love about the show is just
how quickly they can get it's so strange
and weird that can so quickly is there
a character mm-hmm and a personality
just like that because you can just make
them as odd as you want and direct as
you want so yeah like just she's just
really you know they're bashful but
maybe there's a thing for Finn or
whatever it's just happy about
everything it's just like all that
established in two lines I just think
that's so funny
so now that the Peebles is 13 are you
okay with the Finan Peebles being an
item it's done really bad that's still
my gopal okay no hey that's not asking I
mean okay lay put this way I know in
long run probably Finn and Marceline
should not be together because they are
too alike in the wrong ways and not
alike in the wrong ways if that makes
sense yeah but it just seems like it'd
be more interesting television like this
just seems like a more interesting story
it's like wow this can lead to much
greater stuff where it's like if you
gets together with with people's they'll
just be like they're happy good you know
it's like I don't know I just I just
think it'd be a lot more fun if like
they were an item or something like that
and maybe they found a way to make it
work even though they probably wouldn't
but I don't know cuz they are both
pretty crazy you know I mean it's
logically the the setup between fit and
people's makes more sense because she's
a little bit more responsible and he's
you know the go ahead and save the day
just rush into action kind of person and
you know that they would offset each
other but Marceline and Finn are just so
much more fun there's just more comedy
more I don't know so I was just curious
with the whole now that she's 13 but I I
kept forgetting she wasn't 30 I don't
know what difference are you happy
though the Lich may be returning yes
very happy I love like I didn't great if
he was just the snail all the time maybe
he was the man like ah see if he just
like hypnotizes people just threw the
snail eyes and stuff he still has the
ron perlman voice like it could still
work I think you could so be awesome so
yeah I just really funny episode really
good
can't think of too much else anything
else you get um no I mean although I
like how they actually wrapped it up I
like how you said that through last
episode with you know Ice King being so
annoying it helps bring into Finn
actually having to say yes we please
help me I really like that idea that
it's that running and everything and I
love the fact that like the Ice King
actually felt good about helping and
Finn looks at him and goes you did good
Ice King but and and then it just makes
the joke so much money or why she breaks
apart and he's like I didn't kill her
that time you all saw that I mean it's
just like I said it's great when that
drama is working but it's even better
when it pays off for a good job so no
just just feel-good episode yeah really
strong stuff so next one starts the
third season third season okay see you a
third season check please